[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the data science Hangout
I was going to play around with a lesson
I learned from Matt dancho last week if
you've been here before do you want to
try putting a one in the chat if it's
your first time joining today maybe put
a two in the chat
it was fun seeing all the all the people
commenting last week with Matt but if it
is your first time it's so nice to meet
you I'm Rachel this is an open space for
the whole data science Community to
connect and chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to learn about what's going on
in the world of data science across
different Industries and companies
we share the recordings each week to our
posit YouTube so you can always go back
and re-watch or find helpful resources
and these go up to the new data science
hangout site at posit.com as well I was
a bit slow on this but I just put up
Jessie's and Marco's sessions as well
this week
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everybody
here so we love when everyone can
participate and we can hear from you all
no matter your level
experience or area of work
so there's always three ways that you
can jump in and ask questions or also
provide your perspective on on a point
it doesn't just have to be a question
you can jump in by raising your hand on
Zoom here
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if it's something you want me
to read out loud if you're in a coffee
shop or something like that and then we
also have a slidolink which I forgot to
share with Hannah ahead of time so I'll
copy that over in a second here and put
that into the chat
there you go but with the slider link
you can ask questions anonymously too
but I am so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today Eric Nance Eric is a
director at Eli Lilly and Company
podcaster and Community Builder that you
may have seen around the open source
Community a few times we just celebrated
his 100th podcast as well so congrats
Eric I would love to have you just jump
in and introduce yourself and share a
little bit about your role as well
well thank you so much Rachel and um I'm
really thrilled to be here I've been
watching The Hangout since the very
beginning it's really an exciting space
to be a part of and to be a co-host of
you is yeah tremendously exciting so
yeah um so yeah my name is Eric and I've
been in my current role as now as a
director in the statistical Innovation
group at Lily for
now I've been ability for over 12 years
which does not seem like a Time
certainly flies but um yeah kind of my
day-to-day is a mix of a few things and
I'm sure this will probably come up in
the conversation but I kind of wear a
few hats I'm many managers they say I
got a couple direct reports in our group
and so I'm trying to help enable them to
succeed and where I put a lot of my
focus time these days is bringing
Innovative algorithms and designs for
the new clinical studies that we're
trying to launch and throughout all that
process the one tool to unifies
everything is R so literally it is at
the Forefront of what I do whether it's
building shiny ABS internal packages
Consulting and and even with the
community building though I'm sure we'll
touch on as well so I've been in a mix a
lot of different things at Lily but
learned a lot along the way and
certainly happy to share my insights of
that and yeah it's always a never a dull
moment as they say
that's awesome and I forgot to ask Eric
what's something fun that you like to do
in your free time as well so we can get
to know that side too
well the one of them we probably already
know I'm a bit of a hobbyist with
podcasting and general Tech but um other
than that one that maybe people don't
really know about is I grew up in
Michigan so I always grew up a sports
fan in particular hockey's on the big
Detroit Red Wings fan and they've had a
little bit of hard time the past few
years but in the 1990s they were Stanley
Cup champions and those are some of the
best years I've ever watching in sports
so certainly I'm a big hockey fan for
sure
nice well I would love to get the
conversation going around some of the
community work that you do because I'm
always so impressed with all that you do
and I was just curious how did you first
get started in all this and like
podcasting and just getting involved
with so many community events
yeah this is um now it's going way back
a ways but the roots of this actually it
started in my dissertation back in grad
school where I would not have failed to
complete it without R because R had the
package from one of the leading authors
of a manuscript for the method I was
using called competing risk and ever
since that point I not only use that
package to Crunch through the numbers
but then I was able to produce a
dissertation with s sweep which was a
precursor to Knitter and now what we
know of our markdown in quarto so I was
hooked like I thought R was amazing I
never really had training in it until
then so I was just enamored with the
world of Open Source and around this
time I was also getting into open source
with respect to like the Linux operating
system and things like that and as I was
learning things about Linux to help with
my grad school duties I found podcasts
there were some podcasters teaching me
some great skills around Linux and open
source and really helped me in quite a
few situations with some education there
and I thought well I like ours so much
and I certainly don't know everything
about it but maybe if I just start to
put myself out there a little bit and
maybe see what might be receptive to
people and kind of like a little nudge
to Learn out Loud before that became a
catchphrase from Mara so I started the r
podcast back in
2012 2011. I forgot the year but it
really just started me just kind of
learning about R and a lot of the things
that I hadn't had a chance to pursue yet
and lo and behold I started to get some
feedback that people are liking it and I
decided to keep going and I think what
really turned the corner on that was not
just me doing my own learning but to
showcase the brilliant developers
package off authors practitioners that
were doing amazing work and I wanted to
give them a platform to share their
backstory you know how they got to where
they were and that started kind of my
interview you might say sequence and
through those connections just things
happen organically after that started
collaborating with now pause it formerly
our studio quite a bit started to go to
the various conferences and meetups and
lo and behold I was learning so much
from the community that it became a
passion to keep that going and then more
recently I decided to augment that into
like shiny because I'm so passionate
about shiny as well sorry nashani
developer series a couple years ago and
now more recently the art weekly project
to help curate what is available in the
community so all these things just kind
of happen organically but I thought not
many others are trying this route back
in 2012 to put themselves out there via
voice these are only a few blogs out
there but I thought if the Linux
podcasters helped me so much maybe I can
help others in the our community too
along the way and like I said learn for
myself as well but just share it share
it with the world so it all just kind of
happened organically and I'm glad I
stuck with it certainly been off and on
as I say but it's been a real real
passion of mine to share that knowledge
and like I said to Showcase who else is
doing brilliant work in the community
thank you so much much for all that you
do I love that that phrase learning out
loud and getting to see all the
different examples through our weekly to
can I ask you like thinking back to
those early stages what made you so
enamored with open source
it was just the the brilliant technology
behind it and the fact that we could get
involved without having to jump through
maybe a proprietary company to get there
that we could look at the source if we
had questions about how to function
worked and for my dissertation I had to
look critically at some of the methods I
was using so the fact that the package
code was right there on on cran at the
time I was able to look at the source
verify that this method was doing what I
expected but the fact that I could do
that Albedo wasn't as easy as is now
with things like GitHub but still I
could get in there I could read behind
the lines so to speak try things out
experiment
and the fact that just so many
Innovations were happening then the
General open source community that might
take a big company years to get to and
at that point I was just hooked the fact
that I could do this in statistical
Computing with r and then in my general
grad school duties be able to help
others with pretty complicated projects
hooking r with different technology I it
just was addicting to me that I could
blend all this together without having
to be a part of like a huge organization
or sign a bunch of agreements to get
access to things it was just really a
mind-blowing experience that I never
really got wind of until I I discovered
our
that's great thank you
and I just wanted to remind everybody
um I see a few questions coming in on
slido but if you just joined a little
bit into the session you can ask
questions through slido anonymously and
we'll share the link in the chat again
here in a second but you can also just
jump your your uh jump in and raise your
hand here on on Zoom or put questions
into the zoom chat but I see one of the
questions is uh anonymous question was
how have you married your love for R
personally with your professional work
great great question so this is another
mini Story Time as I say but it was
about
a few years into my job where in the
very beginning I wasn't using R to do
very much because I was assigned to do a
more you might say traditional uh study
project statistician role where I was
helping oversee the analysis strategy of
a particular study and as many might
know in life sciences SAS has been the
predominant player in computation there
but that's slowly changing which would
make it to later but um over time they
hooked me into an assignment pretty
open-ended assignment where you're
getting a lot of complicated biomarker
data and this data was huge and we were
trying to use some pretty novel
algorithms with it and that's where R
came into play I was uh finally able to
take what I learned in my dissertation
started applying to actual work at the
day job and then along the way we had
another talented colleague that was
running at that time called the S and R
user group at Lilly and I started
calling into it much like a hangout here
but it was just people sharing what they
were doing small but enthusiastic group
and then within maybe a year or so me
attending that the leader of this group
said hey Eric you know what I think you
should take the reins on this and first
I'm kind of shocked because I've only
been with company for a couple years and
then this great colleague was very well
respected of asking me to do this but
ever since then that's when I thought
okay now it's time to take this to
another level and lo and behold them
leading the internal art group for about
yeah nine eight nine years and that's
been another you know tremendous asset
to my learning and also getting insights
to what others in the organization are
doing with our because sometimes people
might think oh this contribution yeah I
just did a little bit here and there but
I'm like no you should highlight that
let me give you a platform to share that
because we can all learn from your
experience and then you know we'll all
be you know sharing that knowledge
together so definitely helping with that
user group has been a big help and just
that little nudge to do something a
little outside the box early in my
career gave me that little you know I
say nudge to take this further so again
kind of an organic thing but I'm very
happy it happened that way because it
definitely changed a lot of things for
the better for me
awesome I'm starting to see a lot of
questions coming in here in the chat too
I see Libby you just asked one do you
want to jump in
sure I was wondering if you always knew
that you would go to Industry after your
PhD or if you contemplated staying in
Academia
yeah excellent question
um and first would be congratulations
for one podcast here to another so I had
to shout that out
um I did have a pretty inkling early on
that if I was gonna after I started to
decide to do the PHD which actually was
not instantaneous I thought I was just
going to get a master's degree and be
done with it but I had a few people that
were very close to me say if you're
going to get the PHD you might want to
do it now before things get kind of
crazy later in life but then as I'm
going through that I do admit what I
heard from other colleagues those that
graduated in the same program years
prior were really enjoying the
experience being in Industry whether it
was life sciences or or other sectors in
the world and I thought you know what
yeah I I want to make a difference and I
felt like at that time that would be the
easiest way to do it but again I have
offered great colleagues in Academia so
everybody's got their own preferences
but I kind of knew pretty early on that
it was going to be an industry it's like
roll for me and I've been happy with it
ever since
thank you you bet
so Eric you just said we're probably
going to get a few SAS questions coming
in and we have a few on slido for you
one was how have you convinced
leadership in Pharma to move away from
proprietary programming languages like
SAS over to open source languages like r
or python
yeah well that's a good thing we got
some time for this but I can keep this
kind of brief a start but um
it was kind of leading by example a
little bit I think that to show to solve
complicated issues especially what I was
doing in that early assignment with
biomarker analysis I wanted to
demonstrate that the outputs I can get
from this the analytics I can run from
this and do it efficiently to tie into
some really important HPC high
performance Computing infrastructure
which at that time was not very easy to
do in the SAS world I was able to turn
around answers pretty quickly and be
able to share insights with the
leadership the the clinical team and
they were say hey this is great keep
going keep going with it so leading by
example and then honestly the other key
event that's happening across our
industry
is the invent of the now the fourth or
fifth year running our Pharma conference
where now many of us that are passionate
about using R in the clinical realm got
together organized this event from the
ground up
um maybe we have some of them listening
here on the chat here but that really
started to Open Eyes of many of the
industry leaders and and Life Sciences
to say hey look what these people are
doing of Open Source so look how they're
bringing Automation in a seamless way
with integrating r with other pipelines
and generating interactive insights and
it's just really grown exponentially
since then and a lot of this is not
possible without the open source nature
of R what we can grab from the community
but also integrate it with other systems
really easily over its databases high
performance Computing obviously shiny
for web applications there's so many
Integrations that are possible that
other proprietary packages may have some
solutions for but a they cost money B
they can cost a lot of time but if you
build up the talent you can do amazing
things with r and the other Integrations
and I'm not going to sugarcoat it we're
still not quite where I want to get to
yet but we're definitely a lot farther
in the last few years than we ever were
when I started working in life sciences
thank you
it kind of along those lines and another
question was do you have any suggestions
for beginners who had experience in SAS
but are new to R they're any like
specific approaches for better results
okay well time for some hot takes
perhaps um so like like that question
probably insinuates I also started with
SAS I did not know R before SAS they are
fundamentally different so honestly the
first thing to keep in mind is that many
of the practices or maybe tricks you've
learned about how to do things in SAS
probably not going to work with r they
are fundamentally different from a
language perspective so you've gotta
gotta check that to the side a little
bit and go in with an open mind it will
be challenging at first but I'm going to
Echo whatever's in the community has
said is that I would say getting started
with the Tidy verse that's going to be
pretty familiar in the way the pipe
works and other things like that with
deeply or and the like to what you might
do in the SAS data step and historically
so I think the tiny verse eases that
transition a little bit but there are
going to be some habits that you'll have
to grow into but I think the the
materials on line are really great to
get started with this in fact Mini's
data science in a box is a number
excellent resource I think to get
started with that we can probably link
to there's there's lots of educational
materials out there but unlearn the old
habits first before you dive into it
that would be my biggest advice
thank you and just copied over the data
science in a box over to the chat too
I see Javier you had asked a question in
the zoom chat do you want to jump in
next
foreign
thanks Rachel and Eric huge fan of yours
I feel a little star struck here like
I've been following your podcast for
years and I can't believe I just
recently discovered uh the shiny
developer Series so seriously thank you
for everything you're like throwing back
you know Into The Ether here
um yeah I I have always worked for
mostly large companies and
um
when I got into my first real data
science role
um I noticed that a lot of the
you know Excel cleanup tasks or just
like a lot of the mundane repetitive
tasks that so many people are doing on a
weekly or monthly or quarterly basis
it should be automated
um sometimes they are just so
disconnected from data science they have
no like Advocate or no teacher no like
friend to be like there are better ways
of doing what you are doing
um
I also come from a finance background so
I'm sort of nuanced you know my
experiences are nuanced in that way but
have you had any experience trying to
sort of like
advocate for r or you know closet
connect or shiny and trying to educate
these different teams in like Corporate
Finance you know accounting tax
um or different reporting teams and try
to get them to
you know to use some of the the
our tool stack that is at Eli Lilly
yeah excellent question and first of all
thank you very kind words it's great to
see that some of these little Endeavors
have a positive impact that's always
gratifying um I would say that in my in
some of my early part of the career
um I've been pretty fortunate that a lot
of the leadership that's kind of been
more close to me have seen the value of
what I was bringing and being able to
let me take what I'll call calculated
risk to make that happen and in fact one
of those was way back in probably
2011 or so when our studio first now
pause it first released the rstudio
server I worked with our research I.T
group to get me a virtual machine that I
had root access to and they let me throw
our studio server on there because I
thought at the time after playing with
that at home on my Linux systems because
I have a bit of a Linux geek here that
hey this could change the way we
developed this at lowly and I'm very
fortunate that the I2 group didn't say
like oh this this new Young statistician
wants to do what we don't let them do
that no no they were complete opposite
they said hey we're going to give you a
little training on this but you know
we're going to leave it to you and lo
and behold I got people hooked on
developing our code efficiently on that
server then shiny server came along and
I did basically the same thing then and
that's when people started to put little
shiny apps that were doing maybe very
little in the beginning but it opened
the eyes of leadership when they could
quickly do an interactive visualization
of a trial result or maybe a custom data
set and so that leading by example
starting to get the attention of
leadership and then over time my role
kind of morphed into being this hybrid
of a statistician and you might say an
engineer kind of combining the best of
both so that I could execute on these
ideas and again be given the freedom to
try some of these things out
has everything I've done work not
everything there have been a couple dead
ends here and there but I've been
fortunate that the leadership are ready
to embrace an idea of Saving Time saving
money and the fact that I could automate
the creation of maybe you know 100
biomarkers being summarized in one shiny
app versus an RTF output printing 100
pages per marker that got attention just
that little win right there so it it
started small I didn't start big so to
speak but it started with incremental
things and then it got to the point
where people were seeking me out to help
with advice on how they can automate
something with r maybe in combo with
shiny or other you know utilities
instead of them settling for a default
manual process but it didn't it wasn't
overnight it was incremental kind of
wins along the way
thank you
if I see a question over on slido and
Andy I see your name there so feel free
to jump in if you want to add any other
context too they can ask it it's what
can you share regarding building a
community of practice in a larger org in
terms of finding other our users and
growing and sustaining interests
yeah this is sorry I never you know I
say passion area of mine because I've as
I said kind of in the outset the the
idea of bringing people together and
sharing knowledge has been something
I've been excited about for a long time
it's not always easy because again we
have to sometimes fight a little stigma
amongst ourselves that we feel like the
things we're doing with either r or just
in general we're doing of analytics
isn't really that Innovative it's just
like part of the job so to speak but I'm
trying to get people to come out of
their shell a little bit and celebrate
it and not feel like everything has to
be super polished before they show it to
us I really made a concerted effort in
the last few years to say hey we are we
are a welcoming group we would love to
share our ideas if you want advice we're
happy to give it if you have any
stumbling blocks we're happy to help
solve it but even if you just found a
great package that simplified your
workflow we we just want to know about
it like it doesn't have to be anything
fancy so making sure people felt
comfortable that sharing any
contribution no matter quote big or
small has been one of the things we've
really tried to do and honestly finding
a diverse set of topics that we can
learn from because not everybody is
going to be interested in the things I'm
interested in you know right but finding
others to kind of give a different voice
a different perspective whether it's
from you know creating that great table
with GT or automating a pipeline with
you know connecting r with AWS you know
lots of different things are out there
and making sure that there's a protected
time for people to Showcase that having
regular Cadence has always been helpful
too but I'll admit I'm not the best at
it but I try to surround myself with
others that are enthusiastic about the
same things to building this community
so not doing it alone is definitely one
piece of advice find somebody else to
tag along and help along the way
I certainly appreciate that Eric thank
you
um a couple of things I really got from
what you just said that um the piece
we're not doing Alone
um I'm certainly on on track for that um
I work in public health at a large
public state public health agency and
um
there was an our user group a couple
years ago before I came to the agency
um and that I guess sort of fizzled out
and now there's more interest in it and
so I've connected with the person who
was do who was had kind of started
organizing the group previously and so
we're gonna work together and and try to
reach reach a wider
um a wide cast a wider net within the
organization as well and then um and I
love the piece about it really
encouraging the small shares and even
um you know the in the the safe space
we're certainly
um folding in that our agency has
um has both internally facing and
externally facing um uh Equity goals and
so we're um we're folding all that into
our um you know our
um agreements with how we
um meet and and and work with each other
um so I appreciate that as well about
the inclusiveness for you know Forefront
of that so thank you oh my pleasure and
and those things as long as you start
with those everything else is going to
fall in place like it may not always be
easy but if you set those those
expectations set that safe space and and
like I said don't do it alone early on
that's going to pay dividends and trust
me a lot of things I'm saying I have
learned really the hard way but a lot of
it has been organically you know
improving quite a bit thank you thank
you and I'm merely interested in
continuing to have this conversation
with anyone else here in in the group
I'm gonna drop my email in the chat here
real quick and you know if if you're
interested in having this conversation
outside of you know this like please um
get in touch with me thanks
and and I work in public health but you
know if you're if you're thank you yeah
take it to LinkedIn will do I'm gonna
actually somebody suggested doing that
um for the organization to like say are
the Nar users out there and and try to
do something there too
um so yeah thank you
and me this discussion makes me so
excited this is my favorite thing to
talk about
um and I did just want to use the one
minute here to say I am starting a slack
group for Community organizers to be
able to connect with each other and
share best practices challenges tips and
I'll just kind of like get together and
figure out how we want to help each
other too
um I was being careful about publicly
just sharing the link to the slack so I
just made a Google form
um
that I just put into the chat right now
um but we'd love to see people there too
and and continue that discussion as well
or on LinkedIn wherever everybody ends
up talking about it too
but jumping over to a few other
questions I see
there was one on slido Eric that was
does the data science team ever have
trouble getting resources from the IT
team if so how did you navigate that
oh yeah okay enough for Hot Topic for me
um what there it's been a mix of both
I'll say
um what helped me early in my career is
um making great relationships with that
same research I.T group that gave me the
keys so to speak to that virtual server
that has grown into probably my most
valuable collaboration in the entire
company I'm probably sounding strong
with that but it really is they have
helped us out immensely with
infrastructure with our HPC needs and
really pushing the envelope what we can
do with our inside the Enterprise and
how I got there this is a fun little
might say data mishap story that I
shared earlier this year at a data
mishaps conference but I just so
happened in my eagerness to turn loose
on this really complicated analysis to
bring down the entire HPC cluster one
day like I brought it down it went
crashed into a hole and you can imagine
the panic I felt being a new
statistician doing something like that
but this I.T group didn't say oh okay
we're not going to give him any
capabilities of doing this anymore they
took me under their wing and they really
educated me on what I could do better
next time but they said we want to
partner with you we know you've got the
ambition to really utilize the tech in
the best way and we want to bring you
under our wing and that's been really
fruitful so whenever I need anything
from them or they need anything from me
we're we're there for each other
it's not always that way in other parts
of the I.T world so it does pay to build
those relationships with those that
maybe kind of get where you're trying to
get to and they can help translate some
of the processes or some of the Hoops
you have to jump through so I've been
you know trying to keep those going
fruitfully and then it's really just
being persistent and showing why you
need that certain access key or why you
need access to that that API you know
really just showing them what you're
trying to do here and I've been
fortunate once they see the value of it
they're going to go to bat for me to get
it it just sometimes can take a while
because there are many different I.T
groups across security devops and all
the other sectors that you have to
navigate through but you know with the
with the strong relationships that can
that can become easier
I love to see all the chat that's
happening during The Hangout Too
thank you Eric
um mink I I see you have a few great
questions in the chat coming up do you
want to jump in
uh thank you Rachel oh so uh just I'd
like to thank Rachel you know on the
onset because I've been following the uh
series for I think more than a month
I've been joining week on weekend you
know I'm joining in all the great
conversations and I've been looking
forward to the conversation with Eric
you know because the domain I am in in
Pharma and insurance so I I have had
similar experiences of incremental you
know building out Solutions and then you
know having them be adopted in the org
so I have a lot of questions but I would
just keep it short maybe you know two
questions for now one would be like how
do you how do you facilitate your SAS
programmers to you know uh learn or get
into the r ecosystem and you know be
open to it because in my experience what
I've understood is you know SAS programs
try to be in that Tech or domain because
of the stability and everything around
it and plus you know since our studio
rebranded to post it and how they have
launched shiny for python then
serverless no shiny applications you
being shiny uh you know a trainer
yourself what are your thoughts around
it and how do you see the adoptability
of shiny for python in Pharma industry
as such
yeah great questions uh thank you for
those um so with the first one what has
helped us and I will admit again we can
we can go much farther than we're
currently at but one of the wins that
we've had is trying to look at the big
strengths of R in certain situations and
just let things kind of grow from there
so one example is that we've been
embracing quite a bit the idea of
interactive our markdown reports and now
interactive quarto is becoming a huge
um thing we got our attention on but
showing ours our traditional you might
say SAS analyst group that hey with a
little investment in learning how our
markdown works we can give you this
interactive plot of efficacy results
using something like plotly and and be
able to quickly drill down and zoom in
on certain Data Insights from that
visualization that you would have to
produce like 10 12 plots individually to
get to that same result in a static way
and that's actually started to take up
quite a bit with some internal projects
that idea of interactive exploration now
that's not the end goal right I mean we
I mean me personally I have much bigger
goals than that that's why I'm involved
in this our Consortium work group where
we're trying to use R for clinical
submissions straight through and through
where you got some great leads on that
coming up soon so we started with
capabilities that are brought to the
table that are just really difficult to
replicate easily with other proprietary
products so that that helped us quite a
bit so far and respect the shiny for
python yes like many in the who attended
our studio conference Joe Chang
announced it I was glued to my chair
trying to see where this trend would go
I think it's still early days for us in
life sciences for embracing it but at
the same time the idea of a serverless
shiny app has raised a lot of eyebrows
and certainly I'm keeping a close eye on
it and over time I'm sure it it's going
to you know bring some interesting
insights to what we can deploy now it
just so happens that in a lot of the
workflows I'm doing at the moment
they're based in R simply because that's
been a lot of what we've historically
built in my particular group but we
definitely have some that are very
interested in shining for Python and
trying to see how far it takes I just
would say in life science is so pretty
early days but again we're keeping a
close eye on it yeah that's right and
thank you for answering those that's
super helpful because that's what I
understood too for Pharma industry but I
think you know uh in long run you know
that might be the future for newer apps
that would be probably built from
scratch and not the you know uh Legacy
apps probably but I just want to keep an
eye out you know on the great stuff that
you and lld is doing and you know learn
from that along the way so thank you
thank you very much thank you Rachel
yeah thank you
I see Mike you asked a question that
says on a recent LinkedIn post and I
would love to hear what this recent
LinkedIn post was too
so yeah we I had talked in LinkedIn
about you know being a square peg in a
round hole you know being a statistician
but not doing statistics being a data
scientist but not fitting machine
learning or AI models being a pharmacist
but not fitting models or doing that
kind of stuff so and Eric nicely chimed
in and said you know I I know you feel
your pain or something worse to that
effect so I I guess being a square peg
and an organization is a tough thing
right because
you are not like you're not like the
others so what advice would you give
other similar Square pegs who may be
sitting in other organizations and maybe
on this call
well I'm glad you chimed in on this and
I remember when you put that poster I
was like okay yeah I feel seen on this
for sure
and and Mike's a good friend so I'm
really glad you're here um so I think
one thing that's helped me
um as I struggle with this sometimes to
this they still struggle with parts of
this is not being afraid of it but using
the strengths to help better the people
around me immediately and then letting
that kind of spread out so
I won't lie there's some pressure being
known as one of like the r people at the
org that you know that people go to for
questions every week or whatnot but what
I've been trying to do is kind of what I
said earlier bring up others around me
to help you know carry out certain
messages or certain steps and what makes
me that square peg kind of showing where
these skills are applied in what
situation and bring getting some help
along the way and one tangible example
earlier this year that I took on is I
was really sick and tired of putting the
same email response to questions I got
every week about getting access to the
rstudio server getting access to the HPC
cluster how do I launch a shiny app Eric
help I had it was almost like the copy
paste of the response and I got I got
tired of it and when I get tired of
something that's when I'm like I'm gonna
put this down for a bit I'm gonna focus
on solving this right now so I took the
first two months of this year to produce
an Internal Documentation portal written
in Hugo with a really cool theme it's a
document almost every type of info I
thought for enabling people at low to
get started with r I caught this um and
it was in collaboration with the HPC
team so they helped me along the way but
when I launched that
it made me feel like this square peg
thing now I brought value out of that to
others because I took this knowledge
that was in my head most of the time and
I put it out there gave links to people
and now people are refer they're sending
those documentation links to others when
they have questions it's not always
coming on me so I feel fortunate that
spreading that knowledge has helped
there are certainly other aspects where
I don't think I've spread enough yet
that I'm looking at the best ways of
doing it but it also helped that I've
had some leadership recently that kind
of know when they can let me turn loose
on some and they're confident that I'm
not going to steer things in the wrong
direction that I just need a little time
to ruminate and maybe try this idea out
and the risk versus reward they tend to
think okay the reward is greater
potential here than the risk
but there are certain aspects of this I
so struggle with so really it's bringing
others along and making sure not all
this stuff is trapped in my head is the
first thing I'm trying to address in
this ongoing Quest I might say
hope that helps
thanks Eric
I was waiting to see if anyone wanted to
to jump in there I I see Travis you also
put a great question into the chat do
you want to jump in next sure I guess my
joke questions about the Eli Lilly
Twitter account oh yeah
oh fine fine yep
Erica I was hoping you could get a hold
of the parity account and tweet that Eli
is our only now you know um that'd be
that'd be a winner I might even return
to the bird side if that was possible
but anyway my real question
um the was was are there key ways that
you want to see Eli's data stack change
over the next five years let's say
um I think a lot of it is the champion r
at an org end up becoming our
administrators and kind of like have to
learn things that we didn't set out to
learn
um you know like I know how to write our
but I spend most of my time these days
thinking about infrastructural
challenges like what's the right mix of
cloud versus on-prem particularly when
we're talking about life sciences data
that that gets to be a sticky question
um modern database like usage is not a
common thing in Pharma and ncrs because
of kind of software monopolies like
metadata and and others in that space
do you have strategy you can share
around those sorts of things like what
are you all thinking because a lot of
our our usage can be kind of handicapped
by not being able to actually hit a real
database in the way that we would like
are you all developing on that side
oh I'm definitely thinking of it
um and in fact one of the earliest
internal R packages I created at the
company was in essence a rapper to
Hadley Wickham's Haven package that
Imports as they sets into r
I call a coaster very affectionate name
because it's just one of those things
you might say for granted but when you
need it you like it um
I felt like I should never have had to
do that I feel like the data should not
be trapped in SAS proprietary formats
this is where Eric's Car got another hot
take here so hopefully I still have a
job after this but I do think that the
wave of the future and I'm seeing some
work streams around this is looking at
alternative data formats that are more
open that could then be transformed into
what we need for say a submission or
other pipelines but we're not there yet
we're definitely not there yet and
that's why I wrote that internal page I
wanted to lower the barrier of entry for
people around me in the statistics group
to use R for their Innovative work but
not feel handcuffed because the data was
in this proprietary format it's not
perfect though we have some esoteric
errors that I cannot debug because who
who's good at reverse engineering a
proprietary format not me I just try to
Leverage What the community has so I
think until we as an industry kind of
really look ourselves those in the
mirror and say this way we're capturing
data is not going to cut it for the long
term we're always going to have to jump
through hoops and I'm not happy about
that I but I do think they're starting
to get more attention on what we're
seeing the general Tech sector do for
you know voluminous data and easier
access to data I think I think the seats
are being planted but this isn't where I
want to be yet so admittedly at Lily
what we've been concentrating on is kind
of more on the downstream effects of an
analysis making outputs interactive
giving people shiny apps that quickly
explore their results we're having more
traction there immediately because
that's accessible once you get the data
into R then we're able to turn loose on
this but this is an evolving story and I
share the pains that you've been you've
been mentioning there quite a bit
thanks that's a good answer I know I've
been keeping an eye on that c disk Json
hackathon you probably are aware of that
as well that seems intriguing a way to
get out of this SAS 7 and be that um
kind of web that we live in these days
but we'll see we'll see time will tell
but some worth watching yep thank you
very much
can you share that in the chat Travis
yeah sure I'll dig it up somewhere yeah
I'll find it awesome ma'am I see you
just asked a question in the chat too do
you want to jump in
yeah
about to graduate from business
analytics
um but not necessarily the data science
but uh I do have study um quantitative
psychology uh in underground
and I can do statistics with r or python
or SAS but I don't know how to
break in uh to life sciences and get a
job as a Junior entry level data
scientist
um and uh if there's any tips that'd be
helpful thank you
I am living in Boston by the way but I'm
I can move anywhere or remote
thanks for joining yeah yeah thanks for
the great question
um in in the industry these days
um I think some of the best things to
help you might say break in is um maybe
this will go to other Industries as well
and I'm curious what the people in the
chat think of this but even just finding
an example data set or an example domain
that you want to maybe practice some say
analytical skills on and sharing that as
like a blog or another online resource
start building up that portfolio a bit I
can tell you that if I see like a like a
CV or resume come and they ask me to do
like an on-site interview or a phone
interview and I'm gonna look at that CV
if they have a GitHub profile oh yeah
I'm going to be looking at that and I'm
going to be very interested because it
means that they're trying to you know
build up their skill set in the open and
I'm not going to require everybody to do
that because I me of all people I know
how precious time can be especially when
you have other personal responsibilities
but finding some Avenue to put yourself
out there a bit will go a long way but
I'm sure there are quite a few companies
in fact my company just posted a couple
positions we're looking for some are in
shiny town as well to um there's
definitely opportunities out there I
think the key is kind of you know
showing that skill set that you're
building up and then being able to
really you know embrace the idea of
using R using other languages to you
know really do an Innovative analysis I
I agree it's it's not easy in the
beginning but building out that
portfolio I think will be a big help
yes thank you so much for sharing Eric
and thanks Rachel
um yeah for organizing yeah absolutely
feel my portfolio
I thank you and I was just trying to go
grab a few links I think
um Rami Crispin talked a bit about this
in the data science hangout that he was
on too and we talked about it about it
for a bit
um and I see Libby you mentioned have oh
thank you for sharing it Javier just
posted a great shiny template and
tutorial as well and Libby just put that
in the chat
thanks Javier
um jumping through to see a few
questions from slido that I think I
missed a bit earlier
and one was sorry scrolling up oh one
was being at Eli Lilly so long Eric what
have been the biggest changes you've
seen over that time
well there's been a lot uh
um a lot of the change that happened
that uh our most uh Forefront to me were
was an initiative many years ago where
we tried to minimize the time from say a
treatments discovered and and say the
discovery lab to when we can actually
get that treatment out to patients to
benefit from it's kind of called
minimizing that white space to get there
to do that we had to do a lot of things
differently there's been reorgs in terms
of like how trials are designed you know
more emphasis into other functionalities
but within statistics it actually
empowered us quite a bit to push new
Cutting Edge algorithms for Designing
and for simulation and to not just do
the traditional analysis for like a
clinical outcome so the fact that we got
this mandate to be like okay we got to
shorten this time that we're in this
research phase or this study phase then
we had to really put all hands on deck
to put out new Solutions and so that
just brought Innovation out of necessity
but it also opened the door for those in
my group at the time to really think
differently of how we're leveraging R in
the design space and become one of the
industry leaders in doing Clinical
Simulation we definitely have you know
really much relied on a lot of the
functionalities that my colleagues have
made and I'm not going to come here and
say I know all the ins and outs of every
statistical method that's why we have a
team right everybody can specialize in
their key areas but we've all been able
to pitch in and be able to bring that
Innovation to more novel designs that
can shorten that time that a patient has
to be in a trial and you know the
industry itself still has a ways to go
but just that that emphasis on let's get
these treatments out to patients sooner
just organically then brought some new
innovations that we were doing in
statistics and it really gave us a voice
at the table that we could you know
bring some really Innovative change to
how we were doing things in the past so
certainly that's been one of the higher
level changes I've seen and like I said
embracing open source in more than just
a set of very simple ways especially
with r has been a big change as well
because it's still not 100 and probably
never be 100 percent but we've got the
attention in the right places now to
really build some key Innovations and
I've been fortunate to be in in the
Forefront of some of that and bringing
others along the way is what I get
excited about too
thank you so much Eric and I know the
time goes by very quickly here but I
don't think we can let today and without
talking a bit about podcasting and I see
there was some of the uh somebody had
asked a question I think it's Mike I'm
not sure if he's still on
um let me just scroll up but Mike asked
as a can't find it right now but
something along the lines of as an audio
nerd what's your process for recording
and editing
oh yes we get to go to the key corner
here of audio production okay all right
lots of thoughts on this I've gone
through many different phases of this
but I've settled on now is that in
particular for the r weekly show that I
do with Mike Thomas who's been in this
group a few times in the past and shout
out to Mike if he's listening um we
connect virtually using a platform
called zencaster but there's quite a few
like this where you can just have a
recording in the cloud of your voice and
then be able to download that and do
whatever you want afterwards so we we
use that every either Tuesday or
Wednesday morning or afternoon depending
on our schedules to record our voice but
and I bring it down locally and I use a
software unfortunately not open source
but it's also the state of the art in
this called Reaper to do the actual
editing where I can automate a lot of
the voice processing to get like the
levels nice and avoid clipping and and
make everything kind of sound pretty at
least halfway decent and it's just super
blazing fast uh you know exit out or X
out all my little um's or like oh I
botched that person's name wrong I could
do that over again so being able to
smooth all that out and do it pretty
quickly
um that that's been my
um tool of choice for audio editing has
been reapered to ring the voice tracks
in and it's a cross-platform Mac windows
and Linux so maybe an Olympics guy I get
to use that too so that's been helpful
and then for the video side for the
shiny Dev series I know that's not part
of the question but I can't not talk
about the shiny Dev series
um I record everything whether it's a
live stream or my video tutorials with
OBS open broadcaster Studio
it's a lot to get into at first but
actually Jim Hester a former posit
employee was doing a few tutorials about
some of the things he was working on and
I asked him at our studio cough a couple
years ago hey those are great tutorials
what are you using he's a matter of fact
oh I'm using OBS I'm like OBS isn't that
like super hard to learn he's like oh
you'd get the hang of it and sure enough
I got addicted to it so now I use that
for my video production and that's been
a huge win for me because it's so
flexible and members of the Linux
community that I follow have also
supercharged OBS setups and I followed
their lead and bring that into my work
work station over here so OBS or video
and then Reaper for the audio
awesome thank you so much thankfully for
writing them down into the the chat too
I just wanted to
there were so many great questions today
so I'm sure that I have missed a few so
I just want to say feel free to raise
your hand on here if I've missed a
question that that you asked as well I
think there's one over on
slidos that Sam asked a bit earlier it
was what are your favorite open source
alternative apps that you would
recommend folks migrate over to like
Mastodon or standard notes for example
well those are yeah definitely two
favorites currently so we all know the
situation going on with Twitter we don't
have to dive into it but Mastodon has
been kind of where a lot of the art
community is going for social messaging
so I have an account on there I just
formed our Weekly's account on there so
how we recommend Mastodon and for
keeping notes yeah standard notes is a
markdown based open source editor which
I can sync very quickly across all my
devices so anytime I maybe I'm out and
about at a kid's practice and I you know
was on our studio Community or or
another site I want to quickly jot down
the name of a package or a name of a
website then I can quickly write
something markdown bring it into my
computer when I get back and and
research on it and I keep all my
production notes on there I keep all my
conference notes on there of what I've
learned that like our Pharma or our
studio comps so and then other apps that
I use on the day-to-day
um definitely are more on the linen X
and media production side but like I
said OBS earlier I use shortcut for
video editing I use obviously Firefox
and brave for web browsing I am using vs
code quite a bit now for my development
needs alongside our studio IDE so lots
of things in my toolbox and little
utilities just can just add up to to
really help out but those are the big
ones for sure that are in every every
computer I have here
thank you Eugene I see you have your
hand raised you want to jump in
yeah just a quick question I've I've
looked at
um really trying to do a lot more ml Ops
in my current
um sort of role uh in what I'm doing and
creating repeatable scalable flows and I
noticed there's a package called the
targets package which is Eli Lilly
Associated and uh a lot of the
things that I hear about airflow
I one am very curious to know if you're
using targets if it has been a very
robust sort of back end for doing things
how fast you've been able to create
efficiencies with it um because it
really looks at least from the outset
like it's quite a an Endeavor and um it
looks like it could be used for a lot of
different use cases that sort of you
know are in my head and become fast
because it looks like it even has a high
performance Computing back end that can
link with you know maybe some sort of uh
Hadoop Technologies
um you know that are in the cloud so
yeah very curious
so if it very much helps that on our
extended team we'll land out the author
of targets were in the same group so we
get to share knowledge and I learned
from him way more than he learns from me
but yes um targets has been a huge uh
factor in our Clinical Simulation
pipelines and other endeavors to
simplify and automate and make sure we
don't have to repeat the same analysis
over and over again and it's been used
very heavily in our group and yes a
learning curve might be a little bit you
know harsh to start with but will has
the most extensive documentation for our
package I have ever seen yeah you can
you can book that that's recorded will
does an amazing job of his documentation
so you just go to Target's home site
you're going to see manuals you're going
to see other tutorials and he's beefing
that up even more with things like the
bugging pipelines and such so certainly
in ml Ops domain for targets he's the
definitely done examples of that in the
past and we're definitely using targets
quite heavily and future you will thank
you for investing in targets
awesome awesome thank you
thank you and I see thank you Jordan for
sharing the link in the chat too
I'm starting to hear a lot more about
targets sounds like we should have a
presentation on targets at some point I
think Isabella and our team mentioned
that as well
I know we're have a few minutes left
here but somebody had asked on slido
Eric we'd love to see all the links to
your podcast I shared our weekly and
shiny developer series
um anything else that you want to share
with us about how to like keep in touch
with all the amazing work you're doing
yeah that's a great point I'll um swipe
this in the chat right now I did a
little pre-work ahead of that but yeah
you can get in touch with me on LinkedIn
or on Twitter even though I probably
won't post as much on Twitter I'm still
checking it occasionally and my Mastodon
account which I established earlier this
year those are definitely the the three
biggest ways to get in touch but yeah um
Rachel you basically said the shiny Dev
series we have a nice home site for that
you can say subscribe to the YouTube
channel for new videos and then our
weekly just our weekly.org you'll see
the podcast link right at the top and
yeah we always looking for people to get
involved with that project so please get
in touch with us if you're interested
but yeah those are those are the major
paces places if I can say that and maybe
I'll have time to resurrect the old R
podcast that I started with way back
when so that's on my list to do next
year
amazing thank you thank you man for for
uh summarizing those and putting those
into the chat too that's really really
helpful
let me just double check no quite any
questions that I missed is anything on
top of someone's mind that you want to
make sure you're asked today
feel free to just jump in raise your
hand
I think we got I think we got to
everything awesome well thank you so
much Eric for joining us and
seriously thank you so much for all that
you do for the community it's it's
really impressive and I know so many
people have benefited from from all the
work that you do
well thank you for all the questions and
all everything today too
oh this is like I said been a real
thrill for me and I can I can talk about
this stuff all day literally so it was
good to be on here but the data science
hangout is a wonderful place so if you
if this is your first time attending
definitely come back it's a great place
to be
thank you so much and I just remembered
I almost forgot to say next week is
Thanksgiving on Thursday so we won't
have a hangout next week but we'll be
there the week after so see you in two
weeks everybody